Es ist ein absoluter meilenstein google hat den quanten prozessor brüssel
Vorgestellt, er ist der leistungsfähigste
quantencomputer der welt und wäre der schnellste computer der welt überhaupt wenn
Ja wenn da nicht noch ein kleiner haken wäre alles über den meilenstein in der computerentwicklung jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Es ist der nächste große schritt zu auf einen spektakulären moment die
technologische singularität wird diese vorhergesagte technologische singularität ein
Wird die technik den menschen überholen und sich selbst ständig neu erfinden dann ist die entwicklung der menschheit nicht mehr
Vorhersagbar und es könnten riesige technologische fortschritte in kürzester zeit erreicht werden oder die künstliche intelligenz ki
Übernimmt die macht ja den quantencomputer haben einen entscheidenden vorteil sie sind
Dramatisch viel weniger begrenzt als die herkömmlichen computer die aus schaltern und speichern bestehen ihre technische
Entwicklung ist deutlich langsamer und extrem durch die physik begrenzt wärme geschwindigkeit der elektronen
Kapazitäten usw beim quantencomputer ist das vollkommen anders hier gibt es tipps
die auch zwischen zustände annehmen können das erlaubt den quantencomputern weitaus
komplexere berechnung in weitaus kürzerer zeit so können riesige
datenmengen in wahnsinnig kurzer zeit analysiert werden komplexe abläufe wie zum beispiel das klima oder das wetter können viel besser
durchgerechnet werden
Und und und und jetzt hat john martinis
von der university of california in santa barbara den neuen google quanten prozessor vorgestellt der alles bisher
dagewesene in den schatten stellt
72 kubitz auf einem schiff das ist der absolute wahnsinn 20 cubes galten bisher als grenze an 50 cubes ist man jetzt dran aber
72 das ist absolut google will damit nichts weniger als die welt verändern auf einem solchen prozessor könnte eine künstliche
intelligenz laufen die alles bisher dagewesene in den schatten stellt dann das ist die oberste priorität bei google
künstliche intelligenz ki zuerst oder auf englisch artificial intelligence
First bei google hat man sich wie bei ibm für elektronische schaltkreise entschieden in den supraleitenden
Mikrochips integriert sind und mit dem 72 jubels ist man jetzt der konkurrenz meilenweit
voraus noch ist ein rechner mit diesem chip nicht gebaut worden aber das könnte wohl relativ schnell geschehen und dann
Wäre er wahrscheinlich der schnellste rechner der welt aber
Quantencomputer haben einen großen haken sie sind fehleranfällig war eine wettkampf der quantencomputer, im letzten jahr waren die fehler immens ein
ibm rechner trat gegen einen quantencomputer der university of maryland an der ibm rechner war teilweise bis zu
Tausenden halt schneller als sein konkurrent dieser hatte jedoch eine höhere zuverlässigkeit, er kam auf einen wert von
77 bis 90
Während der ibm rechner nur auf 35?
74 prozent kam das muss man sich mal vorstellen
im matheunterricht herr lehrer ich war zu
35 prozent sicher ja das ist schon ein riesiger nachteil allerdings wollen die google vorstand die fehlerquote deutlich nach unten drücken
sie soll unter 0 5 prozent liegen mit einem quantencomputer
Mit neuen kibiz soll dieser wert schon erreicht worden seien ja wenn er als erstes neues zu diesem
Wahnsinnigen thema quantencomputern dass in zukunft noch eine menge zu erwarten und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer bei
Diesen link dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von pixum
mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder an
abstimmungen teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hierbei klicks und passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau mit der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
Draufklicken kampf der kampf am computer da gibt es mehr zu diesem wettkampf ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran